الليو بقول لي وين كنت في 7 اكتوبر كنت في
الظهر وين بدي اكوني لا بقول لي اه لا انا
شفتك جوا في 7 اكتوبر انا شفتك وبتقتل
جنود اربع اسئله سالهم للكل واحد انا بعرف
ان حب اسمعي هو الاربع اسئله طول الحبس هي
[موسيقى]
بتنسان انا صحفي محمد عماد عبيد
اي عمره 20 سنه عايش في عايش في غزه في
منطقه النصر طلعنا من من البيت الساعه 12
الظهر رافعين علم ابيض بس ولا اغراضنا ولا
اشياء ولا ملابس ولا حاجه طعنا من هان
لقينا في دبابه موجوده على باب راس
الشارع عند مقار اليو اند بي بالضبط يعني
احنا بنطلع من شارع عايديه تلاقيها في
وجهي دخلت انا مرقت كنت قا بمشي بمشي بمشي
جنود وهم مش جنود مش قراب عليك بالمره
يعني في بينك وبينهم 100 متر على جبل
موجود عليه قناصات موجود عليه واحد بحكي
بالعربي كويس و في على الجانب الثاني جهاز
في كاميرا قبل ما ياخدني ماطلعتش في حد
قدامي اخذوه بس في كان ناس قاعده على جنب
عدد نساء
اطفال شباب كبار اجنب دخلت قربت علي اطلع
علي اطلع علي لو اطلعت هيك لو بقول ابو
البنطلون الابيض يقدم يجي علي طلعت قتله
قاللي اه انت قلت له قدمت دخلنا هيك لو
دخلت على الجبل هيك بصير يدخلك ممار ت تقف
يعني تصير بينك وبينه 50 متر هو على الجبل
فوق وانت تحت بقوللك بين هويتك واحكي
اسمك اسم محمد ايما جميل عبيد وهي رقم
هويت انا كنت حاسس انه نص ساعه ساعه خلص
يعني انا مع علي ششي كيف بدكان اصلا لو
بيحكي محمد عبيد مع حكايه لو قمت قلت يلا
بدي اروح لاو بيقول لي امرج على الشقه
اللي كلت اشلح كل ولا شلحني كل حاجه وجاب
في واحد قناص مقشر علي صار يقول لي تعال
على جنب المهم دخلت جوه اللي هو صار يقول
انا تعال معي بدات الوضع انه يسو صار يشد
فيا ونزل راسي في الارض قلته قاله واخذ
الاغراض منه وحطهم في كيس انا بدا قلب
الوضع كله واجا ثاني واحد شدني وكلبشني من
ورا بالحديد وكلبش رجلي وغمني دخلنا صار
يمشي في تقريبا ما يقار 100 متر 200 متر
لجوا ورماني على حصمه يمكن هي اسوا حصم
بتمر على اي يعني بتجرح الجسم بطريقه
مخيفه يعني هي نظم انواع التعذيب بتعمل
معك لسه البدائيه رموني على هذه الوضعيه
يمكن ما يقارب ثلاث ساعات بعد لاث ساعات
اج واحد حكى معي لا بيقوللي ماسك ورقه
صغيره رفع رفع عيني صورني صورني في وجهي
بجوال حتى صوروني ققول لي ايش اسمك محمد
يابيد انت من وين قلت له انا من الشاطئ
عشان هويتي مكتوب شاطئ لو صار يكتب يكتب
لو بقول لي وين كنت في 7
اكتوبر كنت في الظار وين بكوني لا بقول لي
اه لا انا شفتك جوا في 7 اكتوبر انا شفتك
وبتقتل جنود قت لا لا اقتل جنود ومين انا
انا كنت في الدار والف شيء يثبت ذلك يعني
يعني انا في حالي وفي البيت وكذا بس انت
بدك تحكي انا كنت ما كنتش انا ما وصلتش
اصلا ما كتش من باب البيت اصلا حتى على
الشغل ما رحتش في اليوميه الا هو اجى واحد
ثاني بدك تحكي ولا بدنا نعمل لك ونسوي لك
وبدنا نخبط فيك ونضرب والله لاخلي الجنود
يخبطوا عليك قلت له تخبط انا ما في عنديش
ايش احكيه اصلا ايش بدك احكي لك عشان
احكيه حاسس ان انا غلطه فصار يضرب فيا انا
عارف ان انا عليش شي او ما كنتش كانت انكن
ابرد يوم في العالم انت فيش انت ما كنتش
لابس ششي حطك في المنطقه هاويه كله هوا ك
كان ابرد يوم في تاريخ حياتي انت جنا
بعديها نقلونا في في بص زي المفتوح من فوق
كون هيك موجودين حطونا على جنب وطول
الطريق اكيد يعني بينجل فيك خبط يخبط فيك
زوج فيك يخبط حدا من الشباب على الراديو
دخنه في بص على مكان زي هو قريب من موقع
عسكري في نوع من المدفعيه كان جنبنا
مدفعيه صوتها عالي تضرب وفي موجود منطقه
هيك زي طينه قعدنا عليه فشاء الاقدار انه
يجي يوم مطر
حافل تشت الدنيا بطريقه حياتي ما تخيلت
انا محبين الشتاء بس في ذاك الوقت كنت
اقول يا رب توقف هال الشتاء عان كان يعني
الوضع يعني انت غير البرد تشتد الدنيا
عليك وانت هيك وضع كنت لابس ولا ولا شي
ولا كنت ولا شي لابس كنت بس يعني شي
الداخلي بس ممكن في الصور كانوا يعني
متعاملين في هذا منزلينه اان يعني قدام
الاعلام ان احنا ناخدهم هيك شكل صارت تشت
الدنيا وهم يعني ز وحشيه زي اللي استفرض
فينا ان شافوا شتا وكنا بنحكي يا رب وكل
الشباب اللي بعيط اللي بناجي هم ما استوحش
صاروا يخبطوا ويضربوا فينا زي الايش ولقوا
في شغله كده نوه لها بيقنع حاله ايش كان
يجي عليا يقف عندي يقوللي انت نخبه انت
قسام يقنع حاله ان انا هيك عشان يضربني
اكثر شي عنده وقعدنا هذ الحاله ثلاث ساعات
اربع ساعات لما كانت هيك على مشارف 12 11
بالليل لما اج بص ب 50 راكب طلعونا فيه
دخلونا في باص 50 راكب ونقلنا يمكن ساعه
ساعه ونص منطقه بعيده على كلام الشباب
اللي انا عرفنا ومن الناس الم الموجوده
هناك لما وصلنا ان هو اسمه بي اير منطقه
عسكريه في بئير دخلنا جواه اللي هو ايش
بعد هذ المده صار يدخل فيك واحد على براكس
براكسين ثلاثه دخلنا اول براكس بصورك بقول
لك طلع على الكاميرا زي الاستقبال بستقبل
بعمل لك ملف طلع حيك على الكاميرا بعد
الكاميرا بيجي دكتور بيقول لك عندك امراض
مزمنه عندك شيء اكشف عن بطنك اكشف عن شيء
نظام ايش بتصير تقول له امراض ما بكتب
يعني انا كنت قبل واحد قال له انا عندي اه
عندي عمره 55 60 سنه عندي ضغط عند سكر
ماكتب مثلا انه يجي حتى مش الزلمه كان ما
بعد هيك ما جاش ولا دهو ضغط ولا سكري بس
هو نزم اجراء بده يخلصوا اخدوني تحقيق نفس
الوضع رجع نفس نفس الوضع ان انا اوحي
اخذوهم كلهم واخذوني على التحقيق دخلوني
جوا لو ققول لي انا معك ضابط المخابرات
اتفضل صار حقيق اللي هو اربع اسئله سالهم
للكل واحد انا بعرف من حبس معان هو الاربع
اسئله طول الحبس هي بتسال وين كنت ب 7
اكتوبر وين موجود اسر وين في انفاق وين
الصواريخ بتطلع او وين مواقع عسكريه حسب
اللي بساله وفي عندكم حماس في الحاره او
في عندكم حماس في اسئله عامه جدا يعني
تهمه او شي لي فش ان هو بس بيشتغل على انه
انا حصيله معلومات يطلع مني بس المهم صار
يشتغل على هذا الموضوع يسال يسال يسال
قعدت على الموضوع قعدت من يومين لثلاث
ايام انا في هذا التحليل يحكي تحقق معي يا
ساعه ويحط ني واقف مشبوح ست ل خمس ساعات ك
معي
مكالمتين اخر تحقيق كان عن جوالي راح جاب
جوالي وقعد فتح الجوال بيقول وال الاستديو
فتح قاعد على الاستديو لو فتح الجوال لقى
كله اطفال شهداء كل انا كنت حتى اشتغلت
ونزلناه واشتغلنا عليه السوشيال ميدي كله
اطفال هي هي اصلا حص اكبر من الشهدا كانت
الاطفال اطلع حيك يقلب كل ما يقلب يلاقي
شهداء اطفال اطفال كانت قبل ما اطلع كنت
مصور مجزره مجزره مدرسه البراق كلها اطفال
وقلت له بقول له اطلع اطلع يا كابتن اطلع
يا ضابط هي الناس اللي بتموت في غزه هول
اللي بروحوا يعني اناصار تواجه بضميرك انك
انت بتحكي عن حالك هي هدول الناس اللي
بتموت ما هو بكون حماس هم عملاهم دروب قلت
له روع مين لو مبرر انك انت تقتل كميه ه
الناس المدنيه لاحظتوا ان هم بيشتغلوا على
على اساسات ثانيه مختلفه احنا بنفكر فيها
في موضوع انه يعني هو بيقول لك هذا المدني
بكره هيكبر ويسير ارهابي هذا الاساس
بيشتغل وواضح كان طالع علي حقد كل سبعه
اكتوبر ووجود اي حد قوللهم ايش بقول انت
حليت في 7 اكتوبر انت اكلت حلو ب 7ب
اكتوبر يعني تخيل لو جش موضوع حاجز انه
احنا كنا تحلينا ورقصنا ب 7 اكتوبر راح
نعاقب كلكم حتى لو ما كنتش متاكد مش هعمل
شي بعديها بيوم اللي اج كشف اسم كشف 25
اسم انا منه فجاه تفاجانا انه احنا ولا
مروحين ولا شي بالعكس حجنا اكثر دخلنا في
شوارع وهيك البص بمشيش ك مشى 10 متر لقدام
ق فجاه ايش
يستقبلنا انا اطلعت اول ما فتحت عيني
مكتوب
بوليس عرفت ان انا ستقبلني الشرطه
تستقبلني وزي نظام اللي بيشتغل على نظام
لما يستلم بده يعطيك الصوره عن هذه
المنظمه الجيش او الشرطه خالد اللي هو ز
ماعرفش ليه استغل موضوع ان دكتور قول هي
غرفه الدكتور يلا ادخل على الدكتور خالد
لقيت ست يعني يمكن اكبر سته اشوفهم جسه
كبيره وناس يعني عضلات وكذا وين الش وين
الدكتوره في الموضوع ويحطون ست
مفار بس يض ضرب في وجهي يعني ماديش ضرب
جسمي يعني بس ركز على موضوع وجهي ست مفار
ست يعني 12 ايد كانوا علي اه يضربه في
يمكن فوق الربع ساعه 10 دقائق متواصلات
اوقع يعني حتى كنت ماش بد تغيب اخر شي اج
الدكتور كل وجه دم وقوللي فيك شي يعني لما
اسالني السؤال قلت لا سلامتك زي ما انت
شايف المهم ل بيقوللي طب يلا اكشف عن جسمك
صرت اكشف عن جسم والله زي ما هو حتى ما
قاليش خد شاش م وجهها قدامه زي طلعنا على
جانب البراكس الاني كان موجود ناز تصورك
ورايا علم اسرائيل لو شافه هيك منظر قالله
لا ما بزبط نتصور لازم ايش لازم يغسل دخلت
صرت اغسل وجابو لي شاي وساب فس نوقف الدم
يلا يلا والمشكله هو بغسل في بضله يغلط
عليه كلمات يعني كلمات كلمات يعني زي بغلط
على واحد مش عارف المهم ضلين على هذا هذا
لو ايش بدك تصورك صار ايش بعد ما خلص
الصوره بدك تضحك يعني عندهم انت بدك تضحك
في الصور طبعا ضحكنا في الصور هي بدك
وديها بده يصير يطلب منك يعني شغلات غريبه
بين انك انت ما بتعامل مع جيش منظم يعني
بيشتغل على الهواء بدك تبوس العالم اللي
وراك انا جاني
الافراج احنا هلقيت اطلاقا ما بنعرفش انه
في حدا بصيره افراجات
كل الشباب ماخذه على مبدا ان في حد بروح ي
الصبح اخر ايام اللي انا كنت فيها موجود
في النقب يجي يزعج اربع اسماء خمس اسماء
ويقولهم هاتوا فرشكم معكم نسحب الفرشه
والحرام نعرف ان هو منقول لو اخذوني فجك
لو ل مش نقل مردو انا متعود النقل دخلك
على مكان برميك وخلاص بجينا ودينا على
الاداره وزي الوضع صيرت تكركب اي بصير في
شي جديد لو دخلنا على تفتيش كامل بق هان
كيف افتش فقلبي صار يدق ان انا لازم اوقع
الراج لقول وقع
فزي مش مصدق بقول ل وقعت قالله اكتب انا
اسمك طلعت بره مش راضي ما بحكيلك انك انت
افراج حتى الان بس انا هذ كله اجراءات ان
بدي ارح كنا مظلومين جد ب نروح يعني مش
نقل جنب بعض يوم الثلاثه بالليل على الفجر
اجوا طلعونا تعاملوا معنا هيك بس يلا تعال
بدون خبط او اي شي دخلنا كان هذ اللحظه ه
بس في شغله راح ودونا على كرم ابو سالم
اشتغلوا كتير على الشغل الاعلام انا عشان
انا كصحفي كنت اركز في الشغلات كتير وانا
بنزل بعد كل هالايام والضرب والظلم اللي
انا كنت فيه بده يتعامل معك انه هو كويس
اخ اخر يوم اجان اواع الناس بدها تروح بس
انه بدك تدوش وبدك تاخدوا
اواع جداد لبسنا اواع وجاب الجرابين وجاب
شبشب وجاب وصابونه وبدك تغسله وزي هيك انه
تمام طلعت قلت يا الله كيف الدنيا انا
صارلي عشان اروح بس ولما وصلت كرم ابو
سالم بمسك لقيت بنزل تحت بفك ايديك وعينيك
من برا عشان مابين الكاميرا بنزل بلاقي
كاميرا في
وجهي وور وقاعد بطلع لك شوكولاته وميه
مشيت صرت امشي في كان في بص يوان بستنى
اخر الشارع ه وصلنا البص وصلونا لو استلم
لنا اليو ان تفضل تفضل دخلوا جوا يقعدوا
ايش بدكم راح نجيب لكم اكل شرب يتعامل
معنا في ناس يعني انا ما دكت الحلوه
اطلاقا فلما دخل صاروا يجيبون اشياء حلوه
كانت يعني ه قمه السعاد وجابوا لنا اشياء
شاي وكذا تمام انا قلت له بدي اكلم اهلي
قبل كل الاكل والشرب طول طلع الموظف قالي
تواصل مع اهلي ايش اكثر شي كنت بتفكر فيه
اهلي كان موضوع اني انا روح يكون حدا مش
يصير له شي موضوع كان ماخذ كل تفكيري ان
انا خوفي بس على اهلي ان انا بالاول
والاخير ايش بده يصير انا بكره اللي بعده
حروح يعني موضوع انه انا ضليت هيك يعني بس
يا رب اروح الاقي اهلي كويسين وبخير روحت
خلص كل حبسه
راحت